Good morning church.
It is a great day,
and we get to start with one of the best things that we do
as a church is watch and participate
and encourage those who are being baptized
because they have already proclaimed their faith in Jesus.
They want to tell you the same thing.
So this is my friend, Kinzie foci,
and she is here to, uh, declare
that she has talked to us about things.
She's already talked to her parents, all of that.
But what she's told us is that Jesus is her Lord and Savior,
and she trusts him with her eternity.
So we're super thankful to do that.
Yeah, super thankful to get to celebrate
that today as she declares that with this illustration of
what happens inside our hearts by being baptized.
And so Kenzie, based on your profession of faith, I get
to baptize you in the name of the Father,
son, and Holy Spirit.
That's Right. Lord, thank you so much
for this illustration of what it means to,
to be dead spiritually
and then to be raised to life spiritually, forever,
and ever to be with you and to know you and to love you.
God, what a gift of grace that that is,
that she didn't work for this.
She didn't earn it, but you reached into her life
and brought her to life spiritually.
We pray for her as she follows you every day, that
as those ups and downs come, she leans in.
Trust you that we as a church come alongside her
and her parents to help her follow you more
closely every day.
Lord, thank you for the day. We get to celebrate that here.
Looking forward to the day we celebrate your return.
In Jesus name, amen.
Amen. It's so good to see.